i got so many texts uh when when first
one coveted hit and people were a little
worried about hey there's gonna be food
on the shelf or uh is somebody gonna be
there at the other end of when i call
9-1-1 uh then of course when the the
somewhere of civil unrest hit us a few
months later uh the same thing i was
getting texts and and phone calls and
emails from people in california in
particular uh asking about what gun
should i get and then them being
surprised that they just can't run down
and just get one we'll take they cash
and walk out with one the same day
or why they couldn't get ammunition sent
to their house in los angeles these
things were a shock to a lot of people
so you're making the the movie and as
you mentioned uh chris pratt is going to
be in the movie and and chris pratt who
who's an awesome actor and what i think
is so interesting about him is the guy
has managed to stay in hollywood despite
his politics being outside of the norm
of of hollywood
how involved were you in in the casting
and just the creation of the movie
because obviously you
writing a book
doing it in your little operation over
there i don't know how i can't say
little but you're very cool operation
over there is very different than when
you hand your baby over to hollywood and
hollywood may not be so in line with
perhaps some of the things in the book
perhaps the type of people that you want
involved etc etc
exactly i didn't know what to expect
going in just like i didn't know what to
expect from simon schuster going in i
thought you know they might want to
change everything and give me some at
least maybe hint that maybe i shouldn't
be uh do you really have to put this in
there about the second amendment or does
your character really have to think this
way they have never even hinted at me
changing anything i've had complete
creative control which is amazing but
when you option something especially
when it's before your first novel even
hits shelves you're not really getting
from a position of strength uh and so
they have all the rights can do whatever
they want and so when you're in that
position there's a lot of trust involved
and i was so lucky that i had chris
pratt antoine fuqua as the director an
incredible show runner and uh the three
of us just got together in the beginning
and what was important to all of us was
keeping that dark gritty violent primal
nature of the of the book because that's
really what resonated with people and
broke it out from maybe others in the in
the genre but the way that chris
prattleman found out about it before it
hit shelves is interesting in that i got
a call from a seal buddy in november of
2017 so a few months before the book's
gonna come out and first he asked if i
remembered him which i did and then he
asked if i remembered what i did for him
in the seal teams which i did not and he
said uh you're the only person that sat
me down in your office helped me through
the transitioning out of the military
introduced me to people in the private
sector nobody else did that always
wanted to say you and i said how's it
going and he said well it's going great
but i heard you wrote a book and i said
yeah it's coming out a few months i can
send you a galley copy it's like a rough
draft thing and uh and he said yeah i'd
like that but i'd like to give it to a
friend of mine and i said who's that and
he said chris pratt
and what was even more interesting about
that is that as i was writing i thought
of chris pratt playing the main
character and i thought of antoine fuqua
directing and another seal bloody got it
to antoine fuqua who wanted it and chris
and antoine wanted at the same time so
finally antoine called chris and said
let's do this together and now we're all
executive producers on this thing but uh
it's uh
credit to amazon for the things that
they could uh well they were concerned
about a few things from the book uh but
really all that ended up being was
concerned and uh once we we talked about
different scenes that we needed in there
uh and wanted to have in there that the
fans would want in there they came down
on the right side of it each and every
time as uncomfortable as it may have
been for them they uh they they sided
with us and it's it's all in there so i
couldn't be happier with how how that
worked out
what do you make of the state of sort of
the um
the mil well what do you what do you
call the genre actually you call
like military thriller or like what
if you have to put it in something
that's a political thriller for the most
part but there's all sorts of thrillers
out there you know there's a lot legal
thrillers and medical thrillers and
dystopian thrillers and all that stuff
um but yeah it's political thriller so
political thrillers and i think of the
more in certain like there's certain
political ones that are very much in the
politics part and then ones that are a
little more in the military part i can
think of so many you mentioned tom
clinton i mean i can think of so many
incredible movies uh from the 80s or
really sort of early 90s that were just
like there were just every other week
there was just another awesome movie you
mentioned hunford october
what do you make of the state of the
genre right now because you know
everything is so politicized these days
i find when i when i open up netflix or
hulu or amazon
for me personally as a politics guy i'm
often trying to avoid politics a little
bit that's that's just me but what do
you make of the general state of things
and i'm a guy i love explosions i love
thrillers i love all of these movies i'm
just curious what your take on that is
yeah it was something that i was
concerned about going in that other
people uh that were involved in the
project were concerned about as well
because as we all know if you've
scrolled through any of the streaming
platforms or gone to a movie recently it
seems like a lot of the movies are made
for people in la or new york and forget
about everyone in between so we really
wanted to make sure we didn't forget
about everybody in between and uh it was
interesting in that a lot of people's
view of hollywood comes from seeing
maybe a clip of the academy awards or a
golden globes and sense of actor or
director or producer on stage saying
something kind of crazy and you're kind
of like oh hollywood people are all
totally weird and oh my goodness i can
see where this is going um but on set it
was i had 350 people on set making this
uh series it's an eight-part series uh
offer for amazon and uh
i'm in this thing called video village
so the executive producers we have our
screens and we have our headphones on we
can watch what's going on and make notes
and and all the rest of it and the other
executive producer told me they hadn't
seen this before but uh so many people
on that set would come up track me down
there and like the hair and makeup
person would come in and say hey my uh
my son is going to boot camp tomorrow
he's a huge fan he follows you on
instagram uh would you sign a book and i
always had a big box of books there and
would sign away or someone would come up
and say hey my son's going on his first
deployment uh can you sign this for him
and absolutely and so we talk about guns
we talk about net land cruisers we talk
about knives
we talk about hunting and just normal
people talk and what's uh what was it so
extraordinary is that they're so good at
their job uh but also they just want to
put food on their on their family's
table and these are just normal
americans that are working hard and we
had american flags up all the teamsters
truck had their american flags flying
and it was it was a special set and
people made a point to tell me that
they've been on hundreds of sets and
they've never felt one uh that was uh as
open and welcoming and encouraging and
positive and just a cool and american as
this one and i i thought that was that
way that made me feel good anyway i can
tell you as somebody that just fled los
angeles after eight years there there
were awful lot of people that i knew
that were in the biz that were waking up
you know that were sort of lefties their
whole life or were into a lot of the
craziness and suddenly they were going
wait a minute i can't get a job because
i'm a 60-something-year-old white guy or
i don't fit this diversity thing or
something else or their the street that
they live on was burning down and they
suddenly got guns i was one of those
people in la that didn't have guns
before all this craziness and then
suddenly reality hits you in the face
and you you kind of change your view on
things
yeah i got so many texts uh when when
when first one coveted hit and people
were a little worried about hey there's
gonna be food on the shelf or uh is
somebody gonna be there at the other end
of when i call 9-1-1 uh then of course
when the somewhere of civil unrest hit
us a few months later uh the same thing
i was getting texts and and phone calls
and emails from people in california in
particular uh asking about what gun
should i get and then them being
surprised that they just can't run down
and just get one we'll speak they cash
and walk out with one the same day uh or
why they couldn't get ammunition sent to
their house in uh in los angeles these
things were a shock to a lot of people
uh who just from what you think in the
news is that oh yeah anybody can just
walk in you walk out with you know some
fully automatic boom boom and stacks of
ammo and all that stuff yet they've been
voting people into office there for so
long that uh that they don't have those
rights anymore
they've outsourced those to a to a
government that uh is
surrounded whose leaders are surrounded
by taxpayer-funded security when they're
trying to take your rights away and we
see that of course all across the
country now but california chicago of
course a couple other play new york uh
stands out uh
stand out from the crowd in that regard
so i did get a lot of a lot of phone
calls like that there were a lot of
shocked people that they couldn't just
go in and get any firearm that they
wanted
you are preaching my language brother
actually i can't i can't say who it is
out loud but when all hell was breaking
loose in la i happened to say on the
show one day i'm thinking about getting
guns for the first time and i got a call
from a major hollywood sitcom star a
woman who would never want me to say her
name on air uh and she said hey if you
need guns let me know and she ended up
connecting me with people and that's how
i was able to get guns because yeah
you're right you couldn't get ammo
either in la because it was because so
many people were flipping on all of this
stuff do you feel a certain uh oh sorry
good noise you couldn't even order it
there's that you can't even order and
get it delivered in in los angeles it's
uh it's crazy that's just a county thing
but but anyway yeah they make it
extremely difficult in the military it
would be like uh
motorcycles on base so they didn't want
you to ride a motorcycle on base so
first they did okay you have to take
this course okay so you have to take
like three days to take take this course
so okay you got to take this course you
have to do like an up you do it every
year and then you have to have gloves
you have to have shoes that cover your
ankle you have to have long sleeves
helmet reflector vests they started
adding all these administrative
requirements and finally it's like okay
you win i'm exhausted my whole this
whole year's going to be trying to
figure out how to ride my motorcycle on
the base here you're fine you've got it
so that's kind of what uh you know what
governments do to try to make it if they
oh we're not making guns illegal well
you're making them administratively
impossible to get like you've done with
concealed carry permits in a lot of
states if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell